right welcome everyone to the town hall
bord and those joining us on YouTube to
the December plans committee meeting
there is no planned fire drill this
morning but should the alarm go off
please leave the building the way that
you came up and do not use the lift
before we start I would just like to ask
committee members to introduce
themselves by stated their name and the
W that they represent and likewise can
the officers introduce themselves and
Sal on my
left
good morning councelor Kit he mil and
Tamar side good morning Christopher wey
sheward good morning councelor Doug
bushby representing pford North and I'm
substituting for counc
question morning Stacy Dory head of
league on governance good morning rosem
Lo represented in Two Rivers and three
Wars good morning I'm Helen Smith the
planning
manager yes chair apologies counselor
Christie councelor bushby substituting
thank you councelor
bushby councelor hes councelor heo
councelor Lether councelor lock
councelor Pennington coun Smith for
councelor weatley councelor
whiter thank you that's eight for and
one exstension
chair item number three Declarations of
Interest members with interest to
declare should beer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interest when the item is being
considered elected members of Deon
County Council and town and Parish
councils who have considered the plan in
application by vir of their membership
of that Council hold the personal
interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned who
consider the application of fresh which
may include further
information item number four agreements
between Parts one and two we have no
part
two item number five urgent matters I
have no the officers have got any Al no
okay item number six public
participation the order of speaking is
as follows a member of the Town Parish
Council two members of the public in
against two members of the public in
support and all of the above have three
minutes each finally the world member
may speak and they are not limited to
three minutes I will read out the names
of those who have registered to speak
when we come to each
application so item number seven going
on to the plan and
applications application number one is
1060 723 Outline Three dwellings at lak
and residential care home and it's on
pages 11 to 26 of your agenda are there
any Declarations of
Interest this
counts thank you chair I'm also du hassy
but also have an open mind thank thank
you thank
you so the officer will now give the
presentation and this has been done
by good morning members members of the
public um yes the case officer is unable
to be here today so I am presenting it
on her behalf um as advised by the chair
this is an outline application with all
matters reserved accept access for three
dwellings it it's it's brought before
committee today as it has been called in
by councelor lavel as Ward member with
the main reason to call in centering
around um access highways and
parking and ju just before I run through
the presentation there is a verbal
update um the you will have seen in your
agenda report that the Environmental
Protection Officer had raised some conc
concerns around drainage a condition has
been recommended by the case officer to
require a detailed drainage scheme as
part of the detailed Reserve matters
which is sort of normal practice however
it was felt that it would it would be
helpful for members to have comfort that
there is a possible solution and um
consequently the applicant the agent was
asked provide additional information and
there will be a slide on that through
the presentation but the additional
indicative information that has been
submitted has been um consulted with the
Environmental Protection Officer and you
can see that they they are now raising
no objection but there will be a slide
on drainage F further along um and whil
it's not on the slide I did just want to
to highlight two points relating to
proposed conditions um and this is
obviously without prejudice to any
decision that members may decide to take
but should members be minded to approve
the
application um it would be your
officer's recommendation that condition
11 which relates to tree protection um
it's it requires compliance with the
submitted oror cultural assessment and
tree protection plan um it would be your
officer's recommendation that that
condition be amended slightly to require
an updated assessment and tree
protection plan as part of the detailed
proposals it shouldn't be assumed that
what that is automatically showing is
what would come forward and you know the
duty would be to try and retain as many
mature trees as possible so that that
condition should members be minded to
support the application would benefit
from just a slight um change to the
wording and then the only other sort of
condition Point relates to
access condition three requires
compliance um with the plans and the
plan schedule as it's outlined there
aren't any plans before you for
consideration other than the location
plan which is which is listed but also
there is a an indicative site plan but
it does show the point of vehicle access
and that is listed in the plan schedule
so it would be prudent to to indicate
something along the lines of the
avoidance of doubt that that plan is
only included for the purposes of
showing the point of vehicle access it
is also referenced in a separate
condition around closure of existing
access and similarly condition a
references that same drawing it would be
prudent to to clarify that vehicle
access is just from the Tad withy Road
and not lakenham Hill so should members
wish to support the application we would
recommend those
amendments so just moving on to the
presentation now um which this
application was subject to a site visit
so much of this will will have been seen
within the site visit this is the
submitted site location plan you can see
that the application site is outlined in
red with further land in the applicants
ownership highlighted in blue the the
red line area extends to almost 0.4
hectares um you can see that the site um
forms currently forms part of the
lakenham residential care home it's part
of the The Wider grounds um you can see
the care home there in the to the to the
south and east of the application site
lakenham Hill is the highway and Med
to the South immediately to the north is
Tad withy Road um the the group of
dwellings um to the the sort of
northwest of the site are um lenham
cottages and um you then have further
Residential Properties along Tad withy
road to the north Northeast um they're
the the the main sort of neighboring
properties so this assisted extract from
the the local plan proposals map um just
just to highlight the the sort of
planning status of the application site
which you can see marked with the Red
Cross so the site does form with fall
within the development boundary for
Norther um which is identified as a main
Center together with appledore and
Westwood ho um within the north Devon
and hge local plan you can see um
allocation nor 04 or just to sort of the
predominately to the north and and west
of the application site that site is
currently well under development for um
residential um in line with that
allocation the the site does fall within
the coast and Ester Zone which relates
to policy
st9 um that policy distinguishes between
developed and undeveloped coast and
whilst this site um isn't developed as
such by virtue of it falling within the
development boundary it is classed as
developed Coast so the the tests that
would be applied were it to be
undeveloped Coast do not apply do not
apply in this
case so this is the current um site plan
um I think key key points to noce note
that is that there is a a current
vehicle access from Tad withy Road um
also um you can you can see the the
relationship with lakenham Cottages
there the care home itself and the
neighbors along the the eastern boundary
of the site the um the Topography of the
site is um such that that the land does
does slope from South down to the north
um as can be seen by The Contours within
this plan um there are various trees on
site and the application is supported by
an our bicultural assessment and tree
protection plan
um I can confirm that none of the trees
on site are subject to a preservation
order so now I'll just run through some
photos so this is this the um southern
part of the site up on lakenham lakenham
Hill you can see the the residential
care home just just up above the wall
there and then again that's looking in
the other direction towards the
west and again there the the care home
with the the highway and and the wall
which which is the the
boundary and it's just showing that that
access further on further on to the
West now this is down at the northern
part of the site so this is Tad withy
Road um you can see the access there
into the the currently under development
the site that's currently under
development and this is looking with
sort of towards um
towards the South so this is the the Tad
withy Road point of access onto Atlantic
way so traffic associated with this
development would be um leave most
likely leaving Tad withy Road and coming
out onto the the main public Highway at
this
point again that's just sort of the the
reverse view of that showing Tad withy
Road bending around and the development
site ahead
it's just showing sort of the character
of of tug withy Road this is to the east
of the
site and again this is the tag with the
development that's currently under
construction um which is opposite
site that photo shows you can see the
care home um the slope of the land lak
inham Cottages are there as well and
also the Tad with e development it's
important to note that with the T with
the development there will be a widening
of this highway and a public footway
will need to be put in so the the nature
of that that public Highway will change
and that's a requirement of the tab with
e
development now just in photos looking
more closely into the site I'll just run
through these so it shows the the
sloping gradient the trees and the care
home and now this is this is within the
site the EXA existing access track that
runs inside that boundary wall withy
Road and this is the property on the
eastern
boundary again that's that same
property again there's lak and
Cottages now these are some aerial
photos that were provided as part of the
submission but um case officer thought
it would be helpful for members to have
sight of them so the areas sort of
dashed in white are
um essentially the cons the areas that
are considered developable um this so
you've got the care home at the top of
the the image there and then lakenham
Cottages in the bottom right so the the
site being proposed for three dwellings
it does sort of fall logically into
three separate
plots again that's further aerial view
showing those different areas in the
trees on
site series of images
there this is the um sort of plot that
is at the southern part of the site and
these images show certainly the top left
hand corner image just shows how it's
it's elevated and sort of looks out over
the Cottages below and
Beyond again some further images within
the
site so this is just sort of
indicatively
showing potentially a level of of of
sort of tree removal and showing how
that site could be sort of stripped down
to provide for three dwellings again
this is all indicative it's important to
note and this again is an indicative um
block plan showing how three dwellings
could be could be cited within the red
line the the relationship
of the plot closest to lak lakenham
Cottages again this is indicative and
your officer officers report indicates
that at the detailed stage um she's
satisfied that an acceptable amenity
solution could be achieved um as you can
see there is a lot of room within the
site for appropriate positioning and
details of elevations and Heights of
building would be for the reserve matter
stage again that's a colored version of
that indicative plan showing three
separate plots the plot at the Rose
southern end would also have vehicular
access from Tad withy Road and would
just have a pedestrian access onto Lake
inam Hill there would be no vehicle
access from sort of Atlantic way Lum
hill now the the applicant has provided
individual um site plans for each plot
again these are purely indicative for
members information so I will run
through them but they are not for
consideration
today so this is the plot um at the
bottom sort of Northeast part of the
site this is the plot at the the
Northwest part adjoining Lingham
cottages and this is the the southern
plot
um the raised part of the
site there are a series of of sections
which
um the case of around throughout the
site was it just showing the
relationship with surrounding
development so you can see the tadw the
development and lenum um care home on
either end here it's just to show how
how the dwellings could sit within the
landscape and the
sections and this this image shows the
relationship with Laken and
cottages and and how a dwelling could
sit within their
context go for those and this shows the
the rosed plot at the southern part of
the site and and
how seeks to demonstrate is it's
unlikely there would be direct
overlooking of those Cottages below
given the distances and the the
topography this is the plan that is an
indicative drainage plan so there is a
drainage hierarchy there are sort of
preferable means of drainage and if
applicants can't um can't develop a site
along a more preferable drainage option
they then work down the high hierarchy
now the the applicant has indicated
preference ultimately to connecting to
the public sewer um that depends on
timings for the tag with the development
becoming adopted by Southwest water so
that is an option otherwise it's looking
at a combination of package treatment
plants or cess pools um at outline stage
the most important thing is for the to
be comfort that a scheme can be achieved
and what this shows is that whilst being
lower down the hierarchy the development
could could provide three sess pools
within the site and that would be
acceptable in terms of drainage and from
the perspective of the Environmental
Protection Officer however at the
detailed stage and as required by
condition 11 um that would be assessed
in more detail but members can take
comfort that there is a possible
solution to drainage orbe it the detail
of that would come forward at a later
stage so finally just to to sort of run
through through the material
considerations um principle of
development the site is within the
development boundary and the developed
Coast therefore the principle of
residential development is
acceptable um it's only access that's
for consideration at this stage however
the case officer is confident that an
acceptable scheme could come forward at
the detailed stage um in terms of impact
on character and appearance also impact
on
amenity sighting and elevational
treatments in terms of positioning of
Windows um there is scope to achieve an
acceptable impact on ameny at the
detailed stage highway
safety the the access onto T the is
considered to be acceptable for the
three dwellings proposed there would be
no vehicular access onto lak andam Hill
and Atlantic way just a pedestrian
access at that top part of the site um
drainage I've just run through there is
scope for an acceptable solution the det
of which will come forward at Reserve
matter
stage the in terms of ecology the
application is supported by a detailed
ecology survey which was subsequently
followed up with a more detailed
assessment of a tree that had potential
to um accommodate bats and a condition
is recommended to require compliance
with the ecology survey and the tree
assessment um subject to compliance with
those surveys it's considered that there
would would not be harm to ecology
in terms of other matters you will see
there are conditions recommended around
contamination and hours of construction
those have been recommended by the
Environmental Protection
Officer um on section 106 contributions
because the site proposes three
dwellings it would trigger a public open
space contribution now as it's outline
um what our normal approach would be is
to include a section 106 agreement that
links to our policy dm10 and our green
infrastructure calculator so to
depending on the scale of the dwellings
that come forward I.E whether they're
two three or four bed that calculation
would be made um would be confirmed at
the detailed stage depending on the size
of those dwellings but as an indicative
sum for three dwellings you're usually
looking in the region of around 20,000
across the typologies so um world
members would be engaged in seeing how
best that money would would be
identified within the legal agreement um
so yeah finally in conclusion the
application is recommended for approval
subject to the conditions set out in
your report and subject to a legal
agreement to to secure green
infrastructure
contributions thank you Edam for that
very detailed report I've got one reg
speaker Mr Richard Hall if you'd like to
come down to the
front
yeah if you like to sit down and you
have three minutes when you're
settled okay thank you for your time uh
the documented plot overview is
incorrect because it doesn't actually
show any pictorial evidence of where the
land is situated for against dalus which
is my property uh on the documentation
on your on council
site um the parking for plot one is
proposed to remove a horse chestnut tree
which has been designated as A1
condition by the AR Boral report um the
parking for this area does not conflict
with the location of this tree so why
remove the tree um Lake lak grounds are
a wildlife Haven and in a time when we
should be planting trees they want to
remove eight of them to uh enable the
building of these three
houses um there is ample space to the
right hand side of um plot one to be
able to put the parking there as an Al
ative uh plot one will Overlook the d h
as the ground is considerably higher on
the their side of the wall it's about
six foot higher than our so we sunk down
below and um there was a privacy issue
looking into the back of our house from
their from the house because they want
to remove the
trees uh the courtyard of lakum Cottages
will also be overlooked um in the
parking area for plot three which might
create a noise privacy and pollution
issue also the uh main grounds of lham
houseold uh maybe with inside the uh
development boundary but this is a
wildlife Haven and um removing this is
also um uh removing part of the
identif identified Northern Gap it's the
last part as they've already built upon
all across the northern the um tab the
section of Northern
Gap uh building of this land would lead
to a lot of distinct historic historical
character identity of these two
settlements pulling down the stone wall
and Gateway on Tab the road to
accommodate plots who will also be
detrimental to the heritage of lakenham
house um a local needs survey in 2017
done by Northern Council identified that
that there was a lack of one two and
three bedroom houses available in the
area and that there was only a 3% need
for anything bigger these needs are now
cover really with the tab the
development uh opposite there's no
identified need for a size of character
of these properties proos proposed on
this application due to the lack of
identified need the proposed development
would not comply with the policy in the
local plan and therefore should not be
allowed thank you thank you very
much I've got no further speakers so
I'll throw the matter open for
discussion who'd like to start
please thank you chair well thank you
for the Pres ation uh as some our
planning manager said this is an outline
application we all other matters
reserved apart from access and the
public speaker mentioned the access that
then in his contribution it would be
obviously much more preferable to have
the uh access to the site from where
it's shown on tadw worthy road on the
proposed plan rather than the existing
which is more or less right on the
corner there it's never used much I know
it isn't down there um
but it is use of land we're looking at
uh in the outline I always remind myself
and everybody of this that an outline
application is simply that can this
piece of land be developed for what is
proposed for three dwellings well it's a
huge piece of land and I know that some
of it reading the reports some of the
receipts if this goes ahead and is
developed is to improve the gardens for
actual for Lem itself uh they are a bit
rund down the gardens but there'll be
still plenty of garden space for
residents of Laken and I know it quite
well because years ago my my
mother was in Laken and when it when it
was run by the nuns so I do know the
grounds well and uh I'm going to move
approval of it chair because I can't see
there's any reason why the outline
shouldn't be gred as the planning
manager mentioned in a uh
presentation all the detail will come
with a reserve matters application uh
and that will be thres that look any
issues of overlooking and privacy and
all the rest of it will come then so I'm
going to move the outline that we
approve it
chair to go chair um I hate to be at Old
for my colleague from northern ult Hill
but I'm afraid I am a OD somewhat um
I've got several concerns I think start
with the fact that it's described as a
windfall site well I had a look in the
local plan and the windfall site is
normally comprised of something that's
been previously developed and has become
unexpectedly available again well that
does not concur with that site so I
don't know why it's called a windfall
site because I don't think an actual
fact it is a windfall site it's a very
important piece of green Gap in our
village and I actually think it should
be preserved it's quite steep in places
I mean Cil Lea's right you could
actually put three houses there um you'd
have to be very careful where you put
them um and I actually think given the
number of very large houses that have
been built ac across on the site that's
been developed at the moment the rather
large site across the way um you
wouldn't really need any more large
houses and although it is just outline I
know the there's an indication that the
houses that are going to be built there
will be quite substantial and I actually
do think if they were and I know this is
not defined at the moment that there
would be a serious overlooking privacy
and imunity issue for several houses
that already exist there so I'm afraid
I'm not with Council leather at all
thank you
chair
concerns think M concern is
s sorry about that yeah um my main
concern is that the site is a green site
it separates um parts of westo from
almost the northern um under st9 the
Strategic policy um in the developed
Coast um um you're supposed to protect
the identity of of the landscape and the
character and to um sustain the
characteristics of the settlements uh it
seems to me that this application for
three houses goes against that
policy um it also um in my view and I
think again concurring councilor
Whitaker um the housing balance you've
got a huge uh development below it going
down to G Links Road where there're
quite a lot of I believe four bedroom
houses possibly five I don't know um
there it seems to me that uh this
application conflicts with our local
plan policy on housing balance that
there's no need for three more large
houses um I suspect that the applicant
wants to put them there because there'll
be nice view of the of the Sea of the
sea um but in terms of housing need I
can't see it um I'm also concerned about
the impact on um on a non designated uh
asset which is lakenham house I think
that's been pointed out by the
conservation
officer um that any development on that
site in my view would affect the setting
of that house um I also have concerns
there's no architectural archaeological
report I don't know why not given that
the conservation officer has
expressed um has indicated that that is
a historic
site um and uh a couple of other points
um yeah sorry going back on the impacts
on a non-designated asset that is
covered by
st15 um if you care to look at that
couple of other points it's been
referred to the effect of of one of the
houses I think plot three on the imunity
of the existing dwelling at the edge of
the site
um and I think the uh public speaker
referred to the ecology the wildlife
value of that site um I mean it may not
it's not a designated Wildlife site but
within the context of Westwood ho there
are a few sites like that where Wildlife
can Thrive um so that is another reason
for my
concern and as far as the windfall
aspect I noticed that while the site is
within the development boundary the
officer notes that it's not allocated
for housing um whatever that means but
anyway those are my main
concerns I was just going to make I mean
right from the chair I will second
Council L's proposal that the is
accepted I second that um I also made a
note about the conservation officer um
she's got no objection in plan in terms
and I was going to ask if an archical
diggers already been cared
out in the
detail so my understanding is there
there's been no archaeological
investigation associated with this
application it's um the
historic senior historic archaeolog
archaeologist at Devon County Council
would normally screen all of our
applications so there's been no comment
made that's not to say that the standard
archaeological condition could not be
applied should members wish to add it
which would require um a written scheme
of Investigation to take place prior to
any development so we could use the
standard there's two conditions that
they normally recommend at outline stage
so that could be included
thank you chair um I just note that the
the call in is um has been made by
councelor LEL in relation to the um
issue regarding access um it would
appear to me that the access is well
dealt with and highways are satisfied
and as is our case officer
um my concern uh against um approving
this would be I don't I don't think that
we would um win an
appeal we would um an an appeal would
would um would almost certainly um win
so I would be voting that we follow the
officer's
recommendation thank you for those
comments any other com yes thanks
benon thank you chair I'd just like to
ask on page 13
representations um there's long-term
residents in lakam and I just wonder if
they were in the consultation list
because they are losing considerable
immunity if they've chosen to spend
their last days there and I wonder if
they've been in the consultation process
about this
application and just checking up on
that I know that we don't know Des have
so many near neighbors but I would have
thought the closest ones would have been
notified any further comments While
others look about that information
well just to mention to my esteemed
colleague on my right that it is a
windrow site because it is previously it
is previously developed it's actually
domestic curtilage of lakenham and as
far as councelor lel's calling I think
she misunderstood with respect to her
the access is not it's hardly ever used
it's not certainly not used by staff and
visitors to lakland they Park as is that
photograph the first photograph we saw
of the what was the old road into
Northern is now a large lay by at the
front of lake and that's where all the
visitors and delivery
vehicles access Laken and itself so uh
it's not used at the back now that
driveway and it is it is domestic
curtilage of lakam and as I said when I
spoke that um some of the it's in the
reports that I read that some of the
receipts from developing this site will
improve the gardens that are accessible
to the residents because it's so steep
they never they don't go down that
bottom end of the garden as far as I'm
aware residents don't in fact very few
of them use the ordinary Gardens but
they will be improve yeah C wh come
back to separate you I to I I I very I
do not feel in any sense esteemed
actually but there we are I just go back
to the business about the windfall and
the cage because not of fact yet it is
within the cage of leum undeveloped it's
never been developed in my knowledge and
that's what windfall is supposed to be
but there we are and I would like
actually to mention highways as well
highways I think have given their
standing advice actually that taby road
is really a lane and it's used I know
because I have family that live down the
road and have to put up with the traffic
that use it as a Rat Run through from
the bottom of lakenham Hill in order to
get down to B's gate rather faster than
they could in any other way so I think
there should be some some actually um
information coming from highways before
the whole thing is moved forward thank
you um so Council Pennington's point the
the individual residents of the care
home weren't weren't consulted we
wouldn't normally have access to such
details anyway given the applicant is
associated with with with the care home
um it's possible I don't know whether
any engagement took place proactively by
by them as applicant we haven't had any
specific representations from from the
residents at the care home so I think
that's all I all I can really say on
that um other than the applicant is
obviously bringing this forward um so
from an operational point of view um one
one would hope that the impact of the
loss of this this element The Wider
holding wouldn't adversely affect the
residence or or the operation of the
care home um just on the winful point um
coun Council W is absolutely right that
the definition in the local plan does
reference privy development sites but it
does say they normally comprise prly
developed sites so they they can can
include Greenfield sites of course
there's a preference for ground field
sites to be developed first um but I
think the import point is that this land
is within the development boundary so
the principle is acceptable um a lot of
concern has been raised around the loss
of the Green Space potential loss of
trees and harm to ecology um careful
consideration at the detail design stage
should be able to address some of those
concerns um in terms of retention of
green green space and that context with
the surrounding area a lot of a lot of
the points are for the detailed stage
that that members who have highlighted
concern I'll write that there is a
principal issue here over the loss of
that wider green area um there another
point is that address
every so
there's return chair just the com from
our
officer what protection is there for
residents who use that immunity to to
take their fresh air because uh um
they're going to be working in the
daytime and my great concern is elderly
population yes and we tend not to ask
the elderly population what their views
are and and I want to put a marker down
that if ever anything comes like again
they're neighbors they're fact you know
they are more neighbor than anybody else
and they live there 247 most the things
be built I would like to see something
in the future to make sure that there is
protection for that thank you very
much let one more Point well just to go
back to st9 you know what's what's value
of it if you know it doesn't apply to
this site retaining the distinctive
cultural heritage that's SL M an
important house in Westwood home
historically and uh protecting the
landscape setting of those two points
you know this is a strategic policy
which should apply to this
site those other comments has been
proposed by counil seconded by myself
that the application is approved but
with amendments to condition
11 condition three and condition eight
and can we add an extra condition about
the archeological dig it would be two
there's only two
discs so can we take a recorded vote
then
isra yes thank you chair councelor
bushby councelor
hes councelor
he councelor Le four councelor lot four
councelor Pennington four councelor
Smith four councelor weatley
councelor
Whitaker seven for chairman two against
thank you very
much so going on to application number
two it's application number one8
46234 retention of the covered seating
can be landed adjacent to key 22 B and
it is on pages 27 to 38 of your
agenda are there any Declarations of
Interest
please no Declarations of
Interest officer will now get the
presentation thank you chair uh Planning
Commission is sought for the retention
of the covered seating canopy
recommendation is for refusal
application is called for land's
committee because the land is owned by
Char District
Council the the site's Lo located
centrally on uh bit of a key you can see
on the satellite
imagery it's just set to the west of the
key and key car park the background
history to the site is that in
1996 uh planning permission uh was
granted um for change of use of building
to a coffee stroke tea shop and then in
1997 PL permission was granted for
change of use for the area in front of
the building and for uses external
seating area and tables for the coffee
and tea
shop the land it's not highway it's
owned by T District
Council
the this is the location plan and the
drop plan so the area of the existing
canopy is not attached to the building
it's just located to the front of
it the the area is within the settlement
of bford it's within the Town
Center the properties are grade two
listed uh property it forms part of a
listed Terrace dates from originally
from the late 1690s and was
refered um in the 19th century
the site's also within the benefit
Conservation
Area uh it's within the critical
drainage area and within flood zone
three so these These are the original
elevations not the existing ones the
elevations prior to the
canopy um being erected which was I
believe
maybe four years ago three or four years
ago an application came in front of
committee approximately two years ago
and planning permission was granted for
a temporary period of 24 months which um
finished I think in October or November
of this year hence the submission of
this planning application for the
permanent
retention so these are the proposed elev
the the canopy although it's not
physically attached to the building um
it's closely related to it it measures
approximately 7.8 M uh in length 5.3 M
wide and up to 3.1 m in height is formed
by timber frame nine Timber column
supports the steel shoes bolted to the
ground the roof is formed from perspect
roof
panels the
the reason for the um 24mth approval was
primarily because of the covid-19
pandemic and the and the issues with
regard to seating within the building
and the separation distances that that
were required at the
time so the this is the first few photos
are from 2018 so these are the street
view photos that show what the site
looked like before the
canopy so that was
erected so this these are street view
photos from June of this year um from
the south looking
North
South at this time of the year the site
is partially screened by I think there's
three ash
trees um these were number of photos
that I took last
week and you can see that obviously the
screening has
gone the the canopy is a lot more
prominent in the in the Street SE and in
the Conservation
Area
so in terms
of the main planning considerations in
terms of the the principle of
development broadly
speaking local planning policy and
National planning policy is is is
positive with regard to uh economic
commercial development the sites within
uh the town a town center location where
normally we would be saying well
we we are favorable to uh development
that uh maintains the viability and the
Vitality of the Town
Center in in terms of this
application a viability argument isn't
isn't being made it's it's strictly for
the retention of the building for the
benefit of of the current owners and in
terms
of obiously
dm9
whilst it looks uh within town and
District centers to to maintain their
viability and
vitality there are a number of caveats
to that and one of them is um retention
and enhancement of the town and the
district Center's historic character so
while the principle of commercial D
might be acceptable there's obviously a
number other important material
considerations so moving on to the
impact on Heritage assets there
are very strong objections concerns from
from historic England and from your
Conservation Area conservation
officer
um great weight should be given to the
conservation of Heritage assets and
while the structure doesn't actually is
not attached to the listed building it
affects list bu settings the setting of
Terrace and wider um listed buildings in
the area it's also the impact on
Conservation
Area U we do have a Conservation Area
appraisal from I think it's
2009 and it specifically mentions the
setting of the key and the views from
the key across to the river and how
important they are and how they should
be
maintained
the the structure in itself is I would
say it's not high quality it is it's a
Timber structure with a plastic
roof previously as you could see from
the
photos has been a seating area there
for about 26 years I think and a on a
tea shop or a coffee shop for the same
amount of time and during that period I
haven't needed to
be a wooden canopy been tables and
chairs and parasols and an awning and
there are a number of number of ways you
could use that space to make sure that
it has a continued use um in in Clement
weather so in terms of Heritage
impacts we do have quite serious
concerns and the tests relate to harm
now in this case it's less sub
substantial harm but then we have to
weigh those that harm against what's the
public interest in terms of the public
interest um the planning balance which
we'll get on
to although there is some weight it's
very very limited because primarily this
is a private economic benefit it's not
it's not a wider public benefit and
although we've
had
um
164 the letters of support and I can
appreciate that there there's a many
members of the public used used this uh
canopy and and it certainly had benefits
and economic benefits during the
pandemic so that argument has now no
longer
remains so moving on
to impact on
immunity
um we don't consider as an a harmful
impact on amuny there are there are
Residential Properties in the area but
there is a
condition um on the on the current
permission which restricts the use of
that area between I think 9 and
5:00 in terms of Highways it's not a
highway highway authorities have got no
objections um there's no there's no
impact on on movement along the highway
which is actually to the uh east of the
site in terms of flood risk and drainage
the building is what it is an open-sided
Timber structure if there is a flood it
won't affect flood risk to any any great
degree demonstrable degree uh in terms
of
ecology there's no there's no no impacts
in terms of uh habitats of protected
species economic benefits as I've just
covered and there are some economic
benefits and they certainly were during
the pandemic but they've now fallen away
the the the economic benefits that that
are left now are primarily um a private
um personal economic from the from the
current
owner um so in terms of the planning
balance the the weight given to the
economic uh benefits are very very
limited and while there was certainly a
need for this um structure by the
business and perhaps the wild Community
during the pandemic and hence the
two-year permission that's that's Fallen
away now and I think it's it's clear
that the the harmful impacts that are
demonstrated in terms of those impacts
on the listed building and the
conservation area way in favor of the
refusal of the application and and
that's the recommendation
here
chair thank you very much for that
presentation I'll now go on to the
public speakers list and public is
Michel
please you three minutes settled thank
you very much thank you for allowing me
to speak and to taking into account my
objections regarding the financial
effect on my business and my health i'
confirm that I've produced a report of
evidence and uh as far as I know
everything in that report was
true council's remarks on the canopy and
the recommendation that the application
should be refused I wasi that temporary
permission should never have been
granted as it gave free use of the land
owned by the public for the sole benefit
of private commercial profits regardless
of the small pavement license fee they
pay if the council permit planning
permission to the canopy they will in
effect be giving away the right to
permanent ownership and use of the area
it stands on the cafe own to use fre and
forever and also to be able to sell as
part of their business in the future
this would be in conention of the
Disposable of public land for private
use the less than market value and I
refer to Circular 0603 Local Government
Act
1972 the general disposal consent the
disposal of land for less than the best
consideration that can be reasonably
obtained I'm sure the councilors are
aware of this legislation it states that
local authorities have the right to
dispose of land but it must be for the
best consideration as it would not be in
the best public interest to sell or give
it away for less if you allow Planning
Commission for this then you are giving
it away three granting mechanic
permanent planning will give rise to
other establishments erecting them as
they will see the free benefits I point
out that if you allow this one then you
open the doors for all to be able to
apply and you won't be able to refuse
them it'll be giv own more public
property for free
um temp Planning Commission did run out
on the 11th of November and a origional
grant stated that the canopy should be
removed within the 24mth period so that
has passed now and it should be removed
the cafe owners did gain considerable
letters that F from friends family and
people that use but there are
68,500 people living in tourage so
68300 people not vote for it and would'
be very upset giving away their
proper thank you thank you very
much our next public speaker is counc
anad speaking as a member of the
public good morning
good
so thank you for allowing oh I can't see
you oh I need it one those two-way jobs
anyway thank you for allowing me to
speak on this application firstly I must
ask you all to consider why you are here
you're here of course because you were
democratically elected by your residents
to represent them and their views on
this Council they have entrusted you to
make well balanced decisions on their
behalf at a recent full council meeting
we agreed to consult residents on our
draft strategic plan one of the key
areas of priority in that plan is to
support businesses and the local
economy we state that we will encourage
businesses and Enterprise through
investment and business
support let's begin that support Here
and Now Now by granting this
application you will all have seen the
Colossal amounts of supporting letters
demonstrating the feeling of your
residence in
torage I do not consider the officer has
waited the argument correctly in terms
of the
balance Co times were
tough businesses had to find their own
path by changing and adapting hence this
canopy was erected it worked it still
does it has proved an asset to this
business where is the logic in making
them take it down we should be relieved
and glad that this business is thriving
in enhancing our keyside Not Another
Empty Town Center shop historic England
consider that this canopy adversely
affects the historic key Frontage of
bidit yet within my ward
which encompasses Celli historic England
raised absolutely no objections at all
at the retention of a very similar
outdoor wooden
canopy that canopy is situated on top of
a listed blme Kil beside an archway and
chandlery store it is completely
surrounded by listed buildings within a
Heritage Village and is cited
as on top of a listed lime kill we as
World counselors should be sympathetic
to the needs of our businesses to expand
whenever and wherever possible isn't it
true that history goes hand inhand with
Evolution towns buildings businesses
people were constantly evolving but I
ask you to wind up please these canopies
nearly sign ify another moment in our
modern history it is within your gift
today to represent your residents and
support this town center business
actively encourage local Enterprise and
so demonstrate that we are a Forward
Thinking Progressive Council that
actions what we say we will do thank you
thank you very
much our next public speaker is
Jen
for
you have three minutes when you're
ready good morning everybody I am one of
the joint Partners within
K22 I'm here to speak in favor of
retaining our canopy which is enjoyed by
so many people we appreciate originally
the Ping commission as youve well said
was granted for a 2-year period due to
co however the canopy has become much
more to the town it's a feature for us
used and loved by the public it's become
a social vibrant bustling hub for our
community of all ages abilities and
backgrounds at Christmas time in
particular with our lights on the canopy
it's photographed many many times by the
public and shared across social media
again has to be a great positive for
bord town since Co it has become The New
Normal with people still wanting to sit
outside it's become very much a way of
life you've heard of the support that
we've had here today from other people
so I don't really need to mention on
that we understand that it is the
council's priority to rejuvenate and
grow the town and Thrive with a growing
economy of which surely outside covered
seating areas has to be part of that
Vision moving
forwards there are many new housing
developments going up in the area
creating a massive need for hospitality
and businesses in our town to thrive to
enable bord to flourish develop and grow
with the future the High Street
currently speaks volumes of needing
Restorations with so many empty premises
however bford has thriving businesses
both in M Street and on the key all of
which maintain a good footfall between
each business why is this this is a
result of us all promoting and helping
supporting each other
we feel that surely local independent
businesses should be encouraged and
supported and not proving to take our
canopy
down surely all the revenue brought to
the town can provide extra Revenue
especially with car parking fees as well
a win-win for all we appreciate the
points that have been raised by historic
England in relation to the canopy
however in one of the most historic
villages in the country namely Celli
planning has already been granted for a
canopy very similar to ours again being
built in wood for the sole use of the
patrons of the red Lon in the canopy
like ours is not attached to a building
and is a freest standing
structure we gave considerable thought
to the choice of materials used and the
sensitive placement between the existing
trees on the key which is maintained the
visual openness of the key to be able to
see the river we feel we've given
prominence to to our neighboring
businesses lastly we would like to give
each one of you here today to consider
what our canopy offers to bord town
especially when it's such an asset to
the people who love using it thank you
very much for listening today thank you
very
much
I
thank you chair well clearly I wish to
offer my support to this application as
a board member for the Town Council and
tus District Council this canopy has
been in place since the co period
201920 And I have seen at firsthand how
popular and well used it is by both
residents and visitors
alike during this period I have not
received any negative comments or
complaints personally and and I believe
the Town Council uh hasn't had any
complaints either commas that had been
made are generally very positive even
that it enhances the street scene that
is this the my own personal view I think
it does enhance the street scene along
that area much has been said about the
conservation aspect of this application
mostly by historic England I would point
out to members that at the end of this
Terrace is a very room building erected
in the late 1960s early '70s with brick
structure and aluminum wind frames the
whole Frontage of Prospect Place is
covered by modern brick
pavers the other side of the road is a
very modern building used by the londy
office and tus District
Council the post office building is only
75 yards
away towards kingy statue
very modern in its design I think it's a
bit disingenuous to describe Prospect
Place in such glowing terms it clearly
is very
subjective the structure of the canopy
is deliberately lightweight and Timber
framed thereby avoiding modern materials
and minimizing its visual impact there
are no foundations it is very much a
temporary structure it has no sides just
a roof
covering I also find it strange that has
suggested that it could be replaced by
using large modern umbrella type
structures or gazebos this suggestion
would in my opinion be much more visible
and counterproductive
counterproductive impact on imity policy
dm1 of the north Dev and to local plan
relates to immunity considerations and
notes development will be supported
where a it would not significantly harm
the immunities of any neighboring
occupiers or users the Environmental
Protection team provided the following
comments having regard to the times of
use daytime only the Environ
Environmental Protection team does not
consider that there would be significant
harm to any residential immunity
furthermore the Environmental Protection
team has received no complaints in
relation to immunity impact since the
introduction of the canopy it is
considered that the proposal does not
cause any significant harm to nearby
neighboring properties taking account of
the above it is considered that the
proposal Accords with policy dmo1 of the
local plan and the requirements of the
nor of the national polic planning
policy framework
framework members please remember that
this app application requires a license
from tus District Council they own the
land such license is usually renewed
annually and they pay an appropriate
rent for that license
if at any time in the future there was
any real pressing need to district coun
has it in their gift to either not renew
the license or
to issue alterations to that license or
indeed request the removal of the canopy
it is not a permanent structure is there
at the wi of taus District Council as
the landowners so even if uh planning
permission is granted today which I
certainly hope it will be that does not
mean that this is a permanent structure
that could not be removed at some point
in the
future one condition which could be
added if consent is granted
today is that the canopy can only be
used as long as there is a cafe
restaurant type facility operating from
that site either by the present owner or
a future owner if it ever cease to
become canopy and reverted back to a
shop of any other description clearly
there would not be any need for the
canopy so that is a condition that could
be applied in this
case members I would urge you as already
been said that this is a thriving local
business we need to be seeing to be
supporting our local businesses and I
would urge members to support this
application thank
you I assume pushing you remain there
take part yeah thank you very
much right there's still further public
speakers so I'll throw the matter open
for debate do you like to kick off
please thank you chair well the I've
written it the decision on this
application is purely
subjective it
is uh to what it and and that being to
what extent the canopy affects the
listed building and in the conserv and
the conservation
area um I will just say that when we
gave the twoyear permission to the
canopy um it wasn't just because of
covid although that was one of the main
reasons it was also to see what the
effect would be in the area what
comments might be garnered in the area
by having the canopy there can see from
the public response to this application
there's actually
231 letters of support for this not 140
of and I'm very disappointed with
historic England's letter I don't
believe we've been to bord and looked at
it I've never known bord key called Key
Street um and when you read through and
printed it off there they speak about
the setting of various other listed
buildings on Key
Street would also be har what are they
they don't mention them why don't they
mention what they are because it doesn't
affect any actually and also policy
issues in this instance there are
several Heritage assets affected given
the prominent position of the structure
in front of the listed building within
the conservation area and within the
setting of various other listed
buildings what are they why don't
English uh historic England mention that
it's a very sloppy letter in my
view then they finish off by saying we
consider that a permanent structure
located in this position would be
harmful to various various Heritage
assets where are they they don't list
them and so I think it's very slack I
would like to see what letter they were
they do say on the basis of information
available to to date we offer the
following advice in response to the
letter which obviously the planning
officer sent them I haven't seen that
letter so I don't know what that letter
said to Historic England but the listed
building is certainly not what it once
was um it's now a row of modern shops uh
frontages and I couldn't have said it
better than councelor Bush be the world
member said but he spoke uh you know he
mentions the modern region the EST AG
office on the end that's been built uh
and the post office it's a modern
building and in the other direction you
got Nationwide Bank another modern
building um The Proposal does not affect
the fabric of the listed building and
when you
look all the all that you can see of the
listed building you can see it if you go
along the key anyway even with the
canopy there is the upstairs Windows of
of the two which were turned from houses
into shops with Flats above in
1929 so I don't believe that the impact
is detrimental at all
um project place is not what it once was
and it's been changed over the years and
as councel bushby said there's a lot of
modern structures in the area nobody's
really thinks it affects the
conservation area or the listed building
behind and I think historic England
should have actually stated what um what
what are the impacts on their alleged
other historic buildings Heritage assets
they don't say that so I'm going to move
that we do approve the retention of the
canopy is a public benefit many of the
respondents who've written in have been
visitors who've said they were driving
along and they saw it there and stopped
and then used other facilities in the
town so it does have a a great economic
wider benefit than not just as the
planning officer said for the
Proprietors of the C there but again as
I would put a condition in that if ever
and I think councel Bush probably said
it correctly if it ceases to be a cafe
in the future or to change their license
or don't renew the license for that area
then the structure has to be dismantled
which could easily be done it's only
bolted into the ground and that could I
like the timber framing I think it's
much in keeping with the key so um I
think there is a wider public benefit
which
outweighs the very very scant effect it
has on the listed building or on the
conservation
area
spon I agree with Council bushby and
councel leather and stop there I think
there's no point
say yeah I mean from the chair just I
was also disappointed in historic
England um and I quote it says the
quality character in per to the
conservation area would be eroded and a
very poor plan in precedent would be set
that could lead to subsequent
incremental harm being caused to benord
we all know that each application is on
his own merits so I would agree with
Council I was disappointed in their
response um but there again the numbers
support letters it doesn't matter
whether you have one or a thousand as
long as it fits with planning policy
then that's okay and then also
highlighted in read exactly what council
bushby has said about the Environmental
Protection Officer has received no
complaints so I too would support the
application
because um ative balance I consider that
um the public benefits outweigh the the
identified harm and it does a call polic
dm1 of the
mbpf and it is would be subject to the
opening A's condition of 10 to five and
also the additional condition about
should the proses sees to be a
cafe and then the canopy could be
removed is that
okay um yeah I find it's very difficult
this
you know which way to go really I mean
all the arguments are very
good um except so commenting that per
Council Le seems to be indicating that
there shouldn't be any listings or
Conservation area area um just a few
points to throw in that the um the
permission was for a temporary structure
and that was understood right from the
very beginning by soon and it was in
very special
circumstances um also it's interesting
we haven't had any um sort of figures on
viability um we don't know what it was
like before the canopy was there I mean
judging from my own observations it was
always quite busy um when they had the
outside tables and umbrellas um though I
can see the attractiveness of the
canopy um as to the effect on historic
buildings just to point out that um the
historical aspect of a town it looks
like is important for its viability and
it's in order for it to thrive as well
and if something damages that
that that that could affect the
viability and The Business of the town
so you can look at it that way as well
so I'm just throwing that in really as
to um I think the member of the public
mentioned you know the disposal if if it
was disposed of I assume that's governed
by a condition from this Council that it
couldn't be disposed osed of and any
sort of profit through to the business
owner and I think we need clarification
as to you know whether it can be removed
in the future if this Council so
wishes
okay whenever I look at any application
I always look at the first thing what
the Town Council and Parish Council have
said and I really regret to see that um
the viop of Town Council want this
application to be reviewed
so I start from there um for me this is
a head and heart thing you know my heart
wants to say yes of course we must keep
the canopy you know it's a real asset to
the town it supports a local business
it's really useful it must be a great
value to them but I also care about the
conservation area and the heritage of
our town which is equally important in
its own way I recognize that Prospect
Place is not what it used to be but then
if we didn't take care of our town and I
often think we need to take more care of
our town quite frankly in many respects
um where would we be and and a not of
caution for me would be if we agree to
this well how are we going to refuse the
the the customs house at the end how are
we going to refuse Oscars on the key or
if the King's Arms want to do it I think
we put ourselves in quite a difficult
position so you can see I am really
conflicted here you know I mean I sorry
did you want to
every you know future applications do
come in it's absolutely imperative each
application is on its own
merits I know that but it would be very
difficult for members of this planning
committee to always follow that with
their heads and their hearts will it not
anyway I'll leave it there I I am really
struggling with this thank you
chair yes
canel uh thank you chair for me the um
balance is tipped by the argument for
the support for local business and I I
regard the fact that there is a
safeguard there by virtue of the
renewable annual
license and I think on that that alone I
would I would recommend that we approve
this
application further comments yes Council
Smith um thank you I just agree with
that I think the temporary renewable is
the is is the safety net that we have um
I also agree with what councilor but was
saying about um about all the the other
issues it's a it's a very very difficult
one um I sympathize with both sides but
I I think our our safety night is the
the temporary um the
tempor you any F comment
just just to add
that planning officer mentioned about
because of Co it was granted for two
years it wasn't solely that as I
mentioned it was to see what the effect
would be and what the public response
would be to have it but now since the
pandemic many people prefer to sit
outside and eat al fresco they like to
be in the fresh air they like to be you
know separated from people they don't
want to be crammed in necessarily as
they might be if they had to just be in
the cafe the C itself so there is a
there is a need for this type of outside
seating the other issue about um parols
and and separate loose chairs which have
been there in the
past there's a very windy situation on
the key there sometimes I think we all
know that and they blow about chairs
blow about par parasols can blow about
there's a safety aspect to having
anything like that and I think it looks
more cluttered than as far more effect
to be honest on the conservation area
than this does but I would like to add
dm17 tourism and Leisure attractions as
one of the reasons as well for approval
chair right so as been by counil letter
second by Council Penington that the
application is approved under policies
D1
dm9 and
dn17 and with the extra condition
regarding the use as a cafe yeah is it
right
yesly yeah thank you chair
um yes I mean just just from you know as
your senior officers point of view just
to
highlight it you you can't place sort of
huge Reliance on a separate licensing
regime in terms of your decision making
today it's it's outside of planning yes
you know that there is there is that
mechanism it is separate but I just want
to make that clear that it's not
something we can control through
planning and it is a planning decision
today um and and again just just to
highlight that both the conservation
officer and historic England who are
Heritage experts have highlighted the
harm under the mppf par 202 and conflict
with paragraph 72 of the list building
conservation era Act of 1990 so that
that is the professional advice that
you've got and it is of course open to
you as a committee as you've discussed
to balance that with the public benefit
um and it's open to you to do that in
terms of the conditions certainly the
plans condition we obviously don't need
a a Time condition because it's already
there um the hours of use and the the
condition that was on before about
removing the tables after five o'l um in
terms of the use of the the building and
if that changes it would be sensible to
be quite specific on that around because
it falls within ed class E it could
change without the need for planning
permission so I think you would need to
be very precise around that and say use
class EB which is specifically Cafe so
any use that is not that it would be
triggered to require it to be removed
and returned to its previous state um
James there any other thoughts on
conditions
yeah um there was just a a thought
around whether there's a need to
condition that there couldn't be further
additions to the canopy but would be ar
viie that they would need consent wait
so I think if you're minded to approve
they're probably the appropriate
conditions to include right so
everyone's then um D D1 d 19 and DM 177
and a additional Clause condition about
the future use be restricted to class E
and that is specifically a
Cather so I think it's the if that use
of host building
chove yeah yeah so people seconded C
voting agreement with those yeah so we
go to the vote
please thank you chair councelor
haes councelor hero four councelor Le
councelor lot councelor Pennington
councelor Smith councelor weatley
councelor
whiter that's six4 and two against chair
thank you very much so that application
is approved thank you very
much
just wait for to sit
down
right application number three
application
number application number three on your
agenda
outline local needs to Inland adjacent
to Barley flat P week and it's on pages
39 to 47 of your agenda are there any
Declarations of Interest
please n so the officer with the
presentation
okay thank you chair counselors members
of the public before you today is
application
one6
[Music]
32223 outline this is all matters
reserved so there is limited information
before you today
um for you to consider and I'll go
through that as we go through the
presentation the application has been
called in by councelor James and the
reasons given are as follows um an
urgently required Bungalow for the
applicant is required um and they have
increasing needs it adjoins existing
local need
development daughter lives in one of the
adjacent homes the son lives in a large
Dairy unit just up the
road um he is able to get family support
and there is a similar dwelling built
for identical reasons 200 yards along
the road as a local needs dwelling the
application before you is as a local
needs dwelling but because it doesn't
satisfy the policy requirement for a
local needs dwelling um I need to ask
you today to consider it as an open
market
do next one
please um so the red outline here is the
um the location plan and this is the
proposed location uh we have an
indicative blue line that follows to the
south of the red line um and that
indicates a proportion of the area um
under the on of the aant um but
obviously not the full extent of
that this is a an over viw just to give
you a little bit of context the
applicant actually currently I believe
lives in The Farmhouse just to the north
of that so you can see that um
development just to the north there the
pin indicates the proposed site um and
this image is just to give you an idea
of of where it within that cluster of
houses next slide please this just
brings it a little bit closer just to
give you a little bit of context in
terms of where it will sit within the
existing
development this is an indicative um
proposal so this is not for you for
consideration today but we'll just give
you an idea of what the proposal is um
in front of us it does give some
identification of drainage for example
um and obviously that's not for your
consideration today uh what it does
however is just satisfies as that
drainage for example is not a problem um
when we look at this proposal um but we
can't really give any weight to this
this just gives you an idea of what it
might look like thank you um so we've
got a few uh images again this is to
show you the wider site um we are going
to utilize an existing access um and you
can see that access in front of you here
this also gives you an indication of the
existing dwellings and the context of
the site before you today um within
context of those existing dwellings
thank
you um it's a closer shot of the
existing entrance thank
you um so I've taken some images of um
highways uh looking West and looking
East um there are no concerns in terms
of that access and and highways and I
believe that highways have offered
standing advice in this
regard this uh just looks Across The
Wider site again we've got the farmhouse
in the distance so that gives you that
idea of proximity to the existing
Farmhouse um and essentially where the
proposed dwelling will be
built um this is just to give you
context in terms of how that land has
changed from
2010 um and that's the the bottom right
hand image there to
2023 um there are references made to um
existing dwellings and I know the parish
council has also made um comments with
regard to those dwellings and so I've
just put the image on the top left there
for you just to give you an idea of
what's in existence whether they are um
local needs or whether they're open
market dwellings um and just to give you
some context to the the information
that's contained within your
report thank you so our material
planning considerations I'll just go
through very very quickly so as I said
to you at the outset this is essentially
principle of development conversation um
it's not supported within policy it's an
open market or is local needs dwelling
um so it it doesn't have principle of
development support um in terms of
character and
amenity I I just refer to my
notes so I have said here that um we
have considered that this is a
essentially the existing development is
a linear development and this would
extend that line um into agricultural
land um along the existing dwellings um
um so it it does not conform to um
policy with regard to character and
appearance and um it's the officer's
view that it would cause harm should
should it be built um in terms of
residential amenity um you'll see that
um Environmental Protection were
consulted they have made some
recommendations and if you are minded to
review um accept sorry um I would
suggest that the conditions that were
offered to you by your inv Protection
Team would be taken on board and
included in any conditions um as
relevant um but it's not deemed to cause
any harm um in terms of ecology and
diversity there there's very limited
information um because we don't know
what the proposal is going to look like
so that will be brought in under any
reserve matters applications highways
have not caed any problems and we are
satisfied in terms of drainage that any
um drainage subject to the hierarchy
that H mentioned earlier can be
satisfied so there are no concerns with
regard to that with that in mind to our
next slide um your officer's
recommendation is to refuse this
application thank
you speaker is Deb
n
yeah you have three minutes thank you
counselor good morning counselors my
name is debie Nukem and I'm the agent
for this application we are seeking to
gain outline Planning Commission for a
local need B L for the applicant whose
Mobility has been greatly reduced due to
ill health he now needs to prepare for
the future where he knows eventually
he'll need to be in a wheelchair medical
records can be provided to confirm his
illnesses his current property would not
be suitable for a wheelchair not be
easily adapted he wishes to remain in
panus week where both his son and
daughter live so they'll be close by
when him and his wife become more
reliant on them they've lived in the
parish for over 20 years his daughter
lives in gley plat which is adjacent to
the site so the proposed Bungalow is
ideally located for her support pank
week does not have a development
boundary there only Community facilities
are Parish Hall and church there are
only two dwellings close to these
facilities so whilst the settlement in
policy terms not what you expect in
reality parish is made up of small
clusters of property properties one such
area is those adjacent to the
application site this adjacent site was
chosen by Tor Council approximately 15
years ago when when following a housing
needs survey it was determined new
dwellings were required in the parish
the council asked for land owners to
come forward with sites and it was then
determined that this area was the most
suitable in the parish Mr bacon who was
a builder gained planning permission for
the properties which was an affordable
lead scheme he completed barley plat
which is an affordable dwelling and
lived in by his daughter but didn't
continue the site due to ill health the
site was sold and the developer built
two further affordable properties and an
open market Bungalow we've noted the
parish council initial comments
regarding the open market B bow being
for sale and has been taken off the
market and used as a rental property
this bangalow would not be suitable for
Mr Bacon's future needs as it's not
fully accessible by wheelchair the main
point in the office of reports seems to
be the principle of development we would
argue that this area is a rural
settlement and that local needs dwelling
is Justified with regard to policy dm24
The Proposal meets a in that it forms
part of a small closely grp built Form B
the scale is proportionate to the
settlement size form and character C the
site is directly adjoining the built
form D the size of the dwelling would
not be any larger than the Justified
need e it would not harm the set's rural
character and setting F the applicant
would enter into legal agreement to
ensure that the dwelling was retained as
a local needs we respectfully request
you to consider the needs of the
applicant and the suitability of this
proposed
thank you C for three
minutes thank you second speaker is Mr
TI um good
morning my name is Tim B
Su
bacon we're here this morning to discuss
a plan and proposal for two bedroom loc
from each Bungalow to provide a
manageable property with a disabled
access and wi
doorways no stairs and a disabled
friendly for us to live in within the
parish where we've been living for the
last 23
years the reason for us having to leave
our Curr property is our health will no
longer allow us to maintain the property
and grounds to any kind of satisfactory
standard due to its
size their health has deteriorated
dramatically over the last few years and
to Enlighten the committee of a few
health issues that we live with day by
day I had a stroke in
2020 followed by
several tias resting in me having memory
an instability from my
feet which has improved but not
entirely that c coupled with spinal
stenosis and chronic back pain and I've
had two total knee Replacements and I
have as Osteo arthritis in my
joints I've been advised by The
Specialist I will be in a wheelchair at
some
point however they can't advise how long
this might
be I also suffer with insulin controled
diabetes resulting in diabetic
neuropathy in my
feet the three I've had three carpal
tunnel operations and I'm awai in a
fourth I also suffer from unstable
angina resulting in a 16 day Hospital
stay in June
2022 my wife also has a debilitating
disease called catic arthritis catic
arthritis is a long-term condition that
causes severe joint pain swelling and
stiffness resulting in making everyday
tasks extremely difficult and painful
our family are in pancreas week our son
Farms a dairy farm next door and his
wife is a community nurse in nearby Hy
hospital and we have a daughter who
lives in plant which is adjacent to the
proposed
Bungalow we're becoming more dependent
on them for help with their everyday
needs and this is why we're here today
to ask the committee to consider a
planning
application the planning officer has not
requested any evidence relating to our
health issues we can provide evidence in
the form of Hospital documents if
required thank
you
thank you minutes to
go our last public speaker is James W
M good morning
everyone I will apologize for I almost
regular appearance now before the
committee trying to defend the rights of
the our community is in rural areas
which is becoming quite and I will come
to something later on that on this
particular
application it's disappointing that it's
a a zoom visit and not a physical visit
because you would have seen the
affordable housing that was already
there and there there as a result of
planning policy of this Council back in
2008 n and 10 where we had an affordable
housing working group that actually went
out looking for sites to provide
a local need affordable dwellings in the
countryside seemed a bit rebellious now
when you look at it on the other hand
we've just sent out emails to Parish
Clarks asking land owners to volunteer
land that could be used to build local
need or CT CPT types of dwellings in
rural areas so people looking at this
will start wondering are we just 20
years nearly behind the curve or we just
reinvented the wheel so I fully support
this it's right next door to existing um
local need dings um and I've got a whole
lot I'd say and I hate reading notes as
you know but there was one thing the
government has just announced a
substantial amount of money to go to an
organization called Acra AC re took me
ages to find out what it meant action
with communities in R England which has
also been administered by uh the RSM
which is the r Services
Network and and this money and I've seen
figures varying from Two and a Half to
80 million which seems a little bit High
to employ a rural enablers to go out and
find where we can build affordable
housing in rural areas and the reason
given is that and I quote nobody living
in a room I do it slowly nobody living
in the rural area should be
disadvantaged by where they
live I think that's a very simple
message that we as a committee and
you're not here to judge on the
policy that should be correct when it
comes to you you're here to judge
whether there is material considerations
that affect our communities that we
should be taking note of and
any documentation should follow that the
principle of our Constitution is the
members at this committee decide what is
material
consideration and then the planning uh
considerations should follow that so on
that I fully support it it is already an
affordable housing site we've actually
got a to family in one of the affordable
housing because the child needed to go
to Bridal school and for reasons which I
won't discuss in public
but we were able to place a family that
was evicted under the 21 notice in one
of the dwellings so you heard from U Mr
Baker his needs and I fully support that
and I just think we need to move on as a
community thank you for your
time there's no further public speakers
so I'll throw the matter open for debate
D like to start off
please this Captain Pon will I just be
clear why no medical reports were
requested to support this application
please
could you put your microphone on
please okay thank you
yeah any further comments
yes can I ask a question rather than a
comment the officer
mentioned harm that would be um
developed or harm that could be done to
the site what harm in particular what
specific harm are you referring
to so in terms of landscape so that
extension effectively that what is
effectively a linear settlement into
open
Countryside
other thing the
comments if you want to approve it you
do have to State
planning material considerations and
policies is one of these applications
whether you vote with your heart or your
head I'm afraid
um could I just ask a question please um
the application is for a local needs
dwelling and it's referred to as an open
market plan can can you advise me as
to the distinction between the
two yes councelor he thank you so the
local plan um or adopted policies
against which that's your starting point
is very clear and the local needs is
only
enabled um as an occupancy restriction
through part three of st7 which
specifically referred to Royal
settlements so st7 is a strategic policy
that then enables the further more
detailed policies in the plan so
st73 then linked with that is policy
dm24 and the key sort of trigger for
local needs therefore to be considered
is that settlement there must it must be
a rule settlement and there's a
definition of rural settlement in the
local plan and this particular site does
not fall within a rural settlement hence
therefore there's no policy provision
for such a use or an occupancy
restriction in this
location C can I just is is it is it
impossible to make it uh a local needs
dwelling in in in planning I understand
that it's contrary to policy but in
these circumstances can it not be
contrived to become a local needs
dwelling so so that that would be open
for committee through their
consideration against that policy there
would need to be a clear justification
to to go against that very clear policy
position so really strong material
considerations um it is open to
committee to to impose a local needs
restriction and this committee has done
that previously where there is no policy
support for it but certainly your your
officers would would urge caution around
that where there's a clear conflict with
the local
plan it's got um if if it's within our
ability to um approve this as a local
needs dwelling having listened to what
I've listened to and weighing up the
balance I would propose that we approve
the application
as specifically as a local needs
dwelling we need to understand what
material considerations are
considerations for that I mean I I think
it's important to highlight
that as officers we have huge sympathy
with the applicant and and understand
the position therein I think that there
needs to be a very strong justification
as to why this is needed um obviously
there are medical concerns and that
desire to be in proximity to to family
and and those are noted obviously by
committee however there are other policy
Provisions that could deliver something
along those lines such as our Annex
policy um which is more about creating
additional conf um accommodation for the
needs of a specific family member um I
don't believe that has been explored um
and actually we would expect to see
evidence as to why you know there there
are existing properties that that can't
be adapted and why there is a need new
build dwelling um so the local need
restriction is more around restricting
it to um the criteria that's set out
within the plan um so so I think it just
needs to be articulated as to to why
that you know to back up that
recommendation um it's it's considered
that that that would be acceptable in
this
location course izes with the
applicants health conditions and and
that and the applicant's fortunate to
own quite a lot of land and able to put
a piece forward for this application I
would have been much happier if it been
a full application with all the
information there including medical
support for his the condition far more
than just an outline application for
that piece of field to have a bungalow
and I've read what panas we Parish
Council have responded with they seem
very skeptical about the whole thing so
I'm going to go with the office I should
propose that it is refused along with
the officer's
recommendation thank you chair I want go
back to dm24 because I prepared for this
morning it was a really contentious
issue the balance is is really difficult
um you've talked about heart and head
and is heart and head here when it comes
down to this point of view and I'm a
little bit mystified by the24 in the
very first sentence in qualifying rural
settlements
now where is the definition I I I missed
where the definition is in rural
settlements okay because it's in P PR
week it's not in the
village is pan week
rural
i s was Lou so sorry um and there are
four parts to that open Countryside
falls into part four the the definition
of rural settlement falls into part
three and that requires um it to be I've
got the exact name this is the glossery
of the local plan okay thank you for
that i' missed that then this is a small
closely um grouped cluster of houses
that at least one identified local
service or Community
facility then I missed that definition
but if I look at your maps and when an
elephant's got a trunk it's an elephant
surely and when you look at where the uh
the housing is and you look at if that's
not a Ral settlement and I think again
highlights the deficiency we have in our
local plan yeah because we as the
planning committee now are put in a
position where we are being show need
and I would like to see more
demonstration of need from medical
reports to support this and I think we
got a joint planning policy committee
that's going to really hammer down what
our local community needs because we
can't get social care workers any longer
yeah they won't go off to work in
supermarkets who is going to care for
the only its family and C says
absolutely this should be
passed but I'm looking for policy have
the M24 because it was rural policy yeah
and I have little else to go on and I'm
really stretched because I remember
Locker remember an application many
years ago in the similar area where we
went with a heart and we paid very
dearly on on the expenses
with went for judicial review the point
here is that that facility that local
service um and this is this is why this
particular area doesn't satisfy that
criteria and the whole purpose of that
is to prevent isolated settlement
without any Community Services can I ask
any committee can you give me any other
policies that I can argue that this
should be approved upon because that's
where I want to go but I have to be very
careful and um I I aware what's
happening here so I leave my comment
there at the moment I'm still wavering
because I want to to approve it but I I
feel I haven't enough at the present
moment C amongst the pigeons then and
I'm going to ask and Smith the planning
manager would it be an option if we ask
the applicants to withdraw this
application and resubmit a full
application given all their medical
concerns etc etc
um I think you know people want to um
approve it we are struggling to find the
right policies I don't know whether that
would be an option my my feeling and and
that you the head of legal and
governance will will I'm sure have a
view as as well is that that there is an
application before you today that needs
to be determined you have a
recommendation for
refusal um it would be open for you to
refuse it or approve it you could defer
another option would be defer all but
that would still be the same application
that's in outline my feeling is you
couldn't resolve to direct that they
withdraw it but I would I would welcome
um Stacy's view on that we we you know
we can't we can't do that um at all and
and I think we're running the risk of
non-determination and and having that
decision taken out of our our hands um
so councelor
Pennington you'll need to find a policy
if you want to go against officer
recommendation
that
I mean
if yeah I mean I do hate the word in the
Open Country Side it's just not in the
Open Country
Side then what policies are you going to
put forward for approval
dm24 in my view it it can be
subjectively it can be interpreted is
being part of of a settlement so have
you got a policy number for that then no
I should be advise
my um yeah so I I would sort of raised
caution around trying to use dm24
because it's very clear settlement and
Rural settlement are different things um
there's a clear definition of rural
settlement and this cluster of dwellings
does not fall within that so your offic
view Clear View is that it would not be
possible to use dm24 as a reason um of
compliance with that as support for the
proposal the Strategic overarching
policy is st7 so part three directly
linked to rural settlements and enables
dm24 so that that isn't applicable here
you're then the only policy your left
which is set out in the in the officer
report is
s74 which refers to the the countryside
as opposed to an open Countryside um and
that says Beyond local centers Villages
and Rural settlement so that's that's
where where you are spatially in terms
of where this site is um and part four
says development will be limited to that
which is enabled to meet local economic
and social needs rural building reuse
and development which is necessarily
restricted to a Countryside location so
the what's enabl in terms of local
economic and social needs would be the
the corresponding policies so dm28 for
example which is a rural workers policy
is enabled through um part four of st7
but a local needs dwelling in such a
location um without firm robust evidence
as well I I would question whether you
could use that but that would be
probably the only policy that you you
could assess it
against to the mppf then rural housing
bullet point
78 the ru there is plan and polies and
decision should be responsive to local
circumstances and support Housing
Development that reflect local needs
could we not use mpbf
78 I think you'd have to articulate what
those those local needs are um the mppf
is a material consideration but you
you're you would have to articulate that
that outweighs the very clear policy
position set by the adopted local plan
which is your starting point that was a
wial thank you chair I I was I was just
thinking and and it's only a thought and
and I'm not in a position to do any more
than that if we refuse the application
today given the circumstances that the
applicant finds himself in and his wife
is it not possible that they will come
back with a full application which we
would be far better actually to consider
and may well in time be able to
approve um sorry I'm I'm new to sitting
on the plans committee and I should know
the answer to this question but I in in
approving an application do we need the
quote policy yes we
do under sort of planning law the legal
duty is the plan is the starting point
so for a legal robust decision that is
your starting point and you only go
against the plan where there are
material considerations that indicate
otherwise um the new leveling up
regeneration act will change actually
that that that element to strong
material considerations so it is
important that that's
articulated we'll come back just one
more point then are the have we not
heard some very material
considerations that that's for the
committee to to put weight to it's
whether you've got you feel there's
sufficient evidence um I think the the
discussion around it being an outline
with all matters reserved it's it's I I
would suggest it's difficult to to see
if if it is a medical reason you're not
seeing actually what is that
accommodation that's being provided why
can't other properties be adapted I
don't know to what extent evidence come
in to to address all of those matters
the the anex policy that we have in the
local plan is very much there for
circumstances like this it's a much more
sustainable way of of meeting individual
needs without um additional homes in in
a location that where the POC doesn't
support it so um it's of course open to
members to to go against the
recommendation but um um I must urge and
I'm sure that the head of legal and
governance would back this up that there
needs to be clear material reasons
linked to policy and the plan is your
starting point there
counts um yeah I was just going to ask
in yeah in process of assessing whether
there was a need whether the officer
actually looked at the bangalow which is
for rent as I gather um next to the side
um was that an admissible to do to see
whether it could be
adapted um so that wouldn't necessarily
fall within my Reit I did check to make
sure that it had been for sale and that
was confirmed through Google um but it
falls outside of my REM as a officer to
enable that that needs to sit
the is next yeah um I hav got to sd7
balanced local housing market um point
two and I really did when I looked at
trying to get reasons before coming in
today I went to this one because it's